the motion was building it wasn't just
like an instant thing oh he just said
that but we were kind of thinking oh he
threw that out that's really good then
he threw that all it's really really
good Oh probably he's got it through
that he threw the one out charged out
against me too
judge was just like really angry at the
prosecution for doing such a bad job the
judge was a prosecutor he knows the
steps that a prosecutor has to go to to
through through to build a case and they
didn't do that and I think the reason
they didn't do that because they thought
that that well this is a simple law
though the case law says you just play
the movies and see if the people are
disgusted by it
we had passion on my side my are my
lawyers were passionate about this case
they feel passionate about what we're
doing I have in the course of dealing
with all the stress and pressure looked
at the charges looked at these movies
looked at my company looked at what I'm
doing and realized that I really love
what I'm doing
I love pornography I love my company and
what I've built I love the ideas and the
fact that I am doing things that some
people don't like but I'm doing them for
good reasons that I've had to think
through and it's important and that
makes me happy
you